oh do you remember these things and all
oh my god guess what guys I'm back in
New York City yeah it's happening I tell
you about it my video for daily grace
for tomorrow but I also talked about
here it's very quick explanation I have
to finish cleaning out my apartment
that's it so I'm back here for the week
until I go to New Jersey for the
holidays but I wanted to give you a
little heads up that this friday at 11
p.m. eastern mamrie Hart of you deserve
a drink here on youtube and i will be
doing something really really fun the
the internet and i hope that you will
mark off that space in your calendar for
it um and i will be telling you what it
is probably starting tomorrow I guess
yeah I guess so yeah I should start
telling you but this friday at 11pm
eastern in the United States time
because some of you might be from other
countries I'm sorry it's gonna be really
early in the morning for you but
hopefully this will be the first of many
things that we do with this um this is
all so cryptic and weird but trust me
it's gonna be really fun put that on
your calendar that's it i'm so hungry
I'm gonna go eat food by